[Music]
okay everyone so this is my spoiler
review of the dexter new blood season
finale so my video is up later than
usual because with most cases and
finales they don't really give you a
screener ahead of time so i didn't have
time to kind of do an in-depth analysis
and prepare a big long video and get it
out right when the episode aired but i
wanted to get this out i want to get my
thoughts on it while everyone's got it
on the mind um i just watched it and
you know i have a lot of mixed feelings
about it and i want to bring up stuff i
said prior review about two reviews ago
i mention that i was worried that it
might go down
the breaking bad route of an ending and
why that would be a worry is because i
still think the ending of breaking bad
is too recent and if you watch dexter
you've probably watched breaking bad
and i think that bothers me in the sense
if i'm going to
rate how they ended this thing
you know you have to consider
originality right what's different about
it what's going to stand out and stick
with you and by pretty much doing almost
exactly the ending of one of the most
popular shows one of the most popular
endings of all time in breaking bad
is not going to get you something that
should be rated i think well i think
that's actually just disappointing in
the sense that you know michael c hall
and clyde phillips they're coming back
to do this thing years later right and
they're only going to do it they said if
it was worth it if it was a good enough
ending
and they want to redeem themselves from
the ending of the original run and
to come through now with you know just
basically a copy of an ending from the
most maybe popular show in the past
20 years is
just absurd to me like what what did
they think the reaction would be you
know so
that really bothers me and
let's just say you're not mad about that
right and we look at the ending and
compare it to the breaking bad ending
because why i'm comparing it is that you
have this anti-hero right and it's this
tragic ending for them they get caught
they're literally lying on the ground
it's like the identical shot of walter
white at the end and what's also
frustrating why it doesn't work though
doing that is because harrison's kind of
taking the role here of jesse pinkman
and the difference between that of them
riding off into the sunset right
is that
jessie pinkman you loved jesse pinkman
you know i don't love harrison i don't
like harrison so
i'm not gonna sit there and feel
connected when he's having his moment at
the end here and happy for him and
that's the problem here is that harrison
hasn't played as that character during
the whole season that we're supposed to
really like and that we're like oh so
attached to harrison you know we're
attached to dexter and
they didn't do a good enough job then if
they're gonna end it this way with
harrison kind of being the one we're
supposed to attach to and feel for a lot
you know that had to be work done early
on and i don't think that was done
enough and i think that's
problematic because the actor is so good
but he's not
the type of character you really see is
likable you're not like he's not someone
you're like yeah i'm behind harrison
i hope to god they're not planning to do
like an el camino spin-off like breaking
bad day with jessie with harrison
because i will not watch and you know
it's interesting from a business
standpoint with showtime that you know
he killed dexter this show is doing
great dexter new blood ratings wise
review wise fans loved it until maybe
this episode but i i don't know what
they're gonna do now because
business-wise yeah you would say
bring another season but you killed
dexter so if you're saying we're gonna
lead into harrison's life now
i would not watch that and even if they
said okay if we want to get michael c
hall back to get people to actually
watch his thing and bring him in maybe
the deb harry roll i still wouldn't
watch that that's not enough for me i'm
not i'm not what harrison is not a
character i want to watch a full show
about i don't like him enough i don't
care about him enough and the other
thing is that what the season did was
you know harrison was the only day of
big red herring and that you know dexter
was wrong about him that he doesn't
really have dexter's exact
violent urges like to the extremes that
dexter does and he doesn't really have a
dark passenger per se it's just anger
like he's talking about so
in that sense that i thought was earned
i thought they did a good job of kind of
misdirecting you there and what was
weird to me and a lot of people were
talking about too is this moment which
is big with dexter and logan and
it did still feel forced in how he
killed logan because they knew they
needed that to have a reason for
harrison to kill dexter and i wish
that maybe harrison's
choice to want to kill dexter and turn
him in
wasn't so just made at the end there and
that was flipped so fast like i wish
that was kind of something that was more
earned and he connects maybe things that
went on the whole season that would make
him want to do that than just something
that just recently happened in that
moment
so
it's frustrating and
i also think i didn't mention much of my
review in the past but it's a good point
about the plot hole people have made
about the ketamine and it being m99 that
he originally used in the series as the
bay harbor butcher and that had that was
a big writing mess up
which it was but i didn't take it as
something that it was like the biggest
deal because it was part of the way
angela found out who dexter was and that
could be frustrating but i was shocked
that they almost highlighted their error
in this finale um because her saying the
big line that about tell me about
ketamine now it feels like okay this is
ridiculous you can't have this big of a
writing error and then highlight it and
make me go along with this that is where
it gets too much now it's like okay come
on this that's like amateur hour stuff
and that really is just shocking that
not even someone like michael c hall
would just bring up like you know why
don't we just have him
like even address it and talk about it
maybe it was originally m990 switch
something had to be put in there
anywhere any scene the whole season and
that would have worked better so
that was strange and
i think what's tough is that
this whole season was you know mostly
really good and like i've been saying
it's been like firing on all cylinders
the past couple episodes i think the
letdown part of it
is that you know it kind of just
felt like it didn't have everything tied
together perfectly from what was
happening in the season
um it feels like all the curt stuff
became a distant afterthought we have no
idea what the deal was with the
billionaire if he was just a red herring
that's his only purpose i still think i
don't like when that's written like that
i think that just having character serve
the plot again is always just
not great writing and frustrating you
always want it to come out of character
the whole way through and how it really
serves dexter not the plot you know and
that's my other frustration is that
what is the show trying to say here if
it's almost saying that harrison is
better off with his father dead but
again taking that route
is going against the person we're
connected to in the show i want the
ending to connect to something about
dexter and i don't like that i don't
like that
if we think of the whole timeline of the
show it's like
to me it felt like i was saying yeah
maybe this guy's just better off dead
you know i don't think that's smart
ending in my opinion and that might just
be personal preference but
i wasn't crazy about that either now i
don't think this was all bad i think you
know it's the finale it's going to be
exciting i was on the edge of my seat
the whole time you know you want to know
what happens here um so i do think it
was suspenseful i didn't think it was
entertaining i think the actress i said
this already of angela julia jones was
spectacular here she's carrying really a
lot of the show and the scene she has to
do at this point because she is the one
who's kind of under duress learning so
much information so i think she's been
great i think jack alcott have said two
harrison's a great actor but again i
don't want to see a show with harrison
the character is not someone to me who's
likable you know and they're saying that
there's going to be this big
announcement on monday about dexter so i
don't know if it's going to be an after
show everyone's going to bring everyone
back or reunion or
if it's going to be you know a new
season with harrison but
i mean i i'm not excited about either
honestly and it's something about also
the way they bring angel back it just
feels forced in and
it sucks if you're going to even tease
him that he didn't even get to see
dexter face to face and we know that
will never come because dexter is dead
and that's also the problem you have
with choosing to kill dexter is that
even if people didn't like this finale
but dexter lives somehow you leave a
door open for people to forgive it and
you know get them still excited for
what's to come and kind of relish and
how great this season really was as a
whole and
that's not the feeling today and it's
really hard to stick a landing and
that happens a lot of great shows and i
haven't said that about the new season
watching my daughter was great great
show great season just didn't stick to
landing i feel the same way about this
show and
it's tougher when it's like a series
finale especially for the character of
dexter and you come back and you know
it's a little better than the original
ending but not by much so that's a
disappointment but i did really enjoy
the season it will bring the season
score down for me a bit i think i'd give
this season
as a whole
an 8.7
i think i'd give the finale as a whole
just being fair you know looking it as a
show and writing acting directing
i'm going to give the finale
an 8.1
and
again whatever you're feeling isn't how
the end of this thing it's disappointing
you come back all these years and you
literally do the ending of breaking bad
it just does not get the original points
it doesn't make its own voice so that's
really disappointing with such a great
character in dexter but
let me know what you guys thought i
really want to hear your thoughts on
this let me know if you want me to do
like a live talking about this where we
can all discuss the finale i think
that'd be fun in the season as a whole
and
please i'm so grateful for all you guys
comments i really appreciate it please
subscribe it helps me in so many ways
you have no idea i'd really appreciate
if you really love to do here become a
member today it will support me do this
full time one day and do more videos for
you guys you also get perks as well but
i really appreciate it i always enjoy
people who watch my videos and your
comments and i love seeing you guys come
on to other shows and movies i do even
interviews so that'd be awesome but
either way i'm grateful for everything
you've given me
and i'll see you next time